mais après vingt ans de présence en
afghanistan plus de 2000 milliards de
dollars dépensés la mort de près de 2500
américain les états unis ont donc quitté
le pays et n'aura fallu que trois mois
d'offensive aux talibans pour prendre le
contrôle du territoire et de son côté la
russie aujourd'hui positive les
assurances données par les talibans de
moscou qui souhaite également un
dialogue de toutes les forces politiques
ethniques et confessionnelles ont fait
le point depuis moscou avec notre
correspondant antoine claireaux sans
surprise la russie dresse un bilan peu
reluisant de ces vingt années de
présence américaine en afghanistan et en
particulier sur les justifications des
états unis qui leur permettent
aujourd'hui de quitter le pays la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe en quelque
sorte répondu aux propos de responsables
américains aux propos de joe biden qui
estime que les objectifs ont été remplis
la résolution
1386 du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
indique clairement que le but de la
force internationale d'assistance à la
sécurité et d'aider l'autorité
intérimaire afghanes à assurer la
sécurité à kaboul et dans ses environs
afin que l'autorité intérimaire afghanes
et le personnel des nations unies
puissent opérer dans un environnement
sécurisé le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
a décidé en octobre 2003 d'étendre la
mission au delà de kaboul
l'élargissement s'est déroulée
progressivement et s'est achevée en
octobre 2006 lorsque la force
internationale a pris la responsabilité
d'assurer la sécurité dans l'ensemble du
pays le renforcement du contingent
présent en afghanistan avait pour but de
contenir l'activité des militants
talibans en donnant aux afghans le temps
de prendre le contrôle du pays vous
pouvez désormais juger par vous même si
ces objectifs ont été atteints ou non le
président de la chambre basse du
parlement russe parle lui d'un
effondrement de la politique étrangère
américaine
le séjour de vingt ans des troupes
américaines en afghanistan se solde par
une tragédie est une catastrophe
humanitaire les laboratoires de
fabrication de drogue se sont
multipliées par centaines la population
s'est appauvri et plus de 250 mille
civils sont morts à la suite des
opérations militaires de l'otan et des
actes de terroristes nous voyons
désormais les images terribles de ce qui
est en train de se passer que va-t-il
arriver on ne peut que spéculer d'autres
responsables russes ont pointé du doigt
le coût humain et financier de ce
conflit et maintenant il va bien falloir
payer les pots cassés d'autant que la
russie compte de nombreux alliés
stratégiques qui partage une frontière
avec l'afghanistan et cette nouvelle
donne aura probablement de très lourdes
conséquences dans cette région du monde